the 20th century's most successful
political idea is under attack
democracy is facing a crisis of
confidence the quality of democracy is
in decline a gap is growing between
people and the political elites elected
to represent them
[Music]
powerful interests have corrupted the
ways people are governed it was very
frustrating because people were dying
and fledgling democracies are
increasingly succumbing to the lure of
autocracy any time we're done you still
believe their business on our darkest
place but how deep is this crisis and
how worried should the world be
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
this Dan has become a young voice of the
Sheila Jean
the nationwide protest movement against
the French government at its height in
2018 the movement made headlines around
the world
[Music]
this turns music videos has had millions
of views online
this is possible demo some chapala to
mom at the heart of his music is a
strong sense of dissatisfaction with
France's governing class
[Music]
Tsukasa Hilda Street typically
manageable and for statistically Friday
night in distance hometown of Toulouse
in southwest France the stands about to
start Agee the crowd are up for it most
of the people here are members of the G
lays on everyone here lives in one of
the world's oldest democracies
but you won't find anyone who thinks
elected politicians represent them
[Applause]
France for a long time had a system in
which a group of very highly qualified
technocrats and politicians were
entrusted to run the country for
everybody's benefit and they did very
well out of it but the whole country did
out of it that system started to break
down as early as of 1990s it came to a
head more recently with the July shown
[Applause]
[Music]
every Saturday dist an and the other G
legend take to the streets to voice
their frustrations
[Music]
[Applause]
Masaki way for another folk arts between
October 2018 and April 2019 the Sheila
Jean protests caused major disruption in
cities and towns across France initially
a rebellion in rural France against a
hike in fuel taxes the movement grew
into a wider protest against the entire
political class
[Music]
Liberty fraternity psychosis enhancement
in appeal actuality or Bakula song
seung-heon system
policing beaucoup
[Applause]
after the government abolished the fuel
tanks the Sheila Jean movement declined
and is now dominated by political
extremists
but Distan insists that here in toulouse
they still reflect the feelings of
ordinary people who feel shut out and
unrepresented by the political system
the popular 50% with our little Maina
see person solicitor and republican said
the Hawaii the desired capital city
discern equally they are about to spoil
our cause
in recent years the strength of anger
towards the governing class in France
has risen admits to climate of growing
resentment and extremism
today in France almost 70 percent
believe their politicians are corrupt
research suggests only 32% of the
population trust the government while
the global average is 47%
[Music]
[Applause]
that's good opposed Shakira me opposes
sonny perdue has somebody that goes
sonny perdue has some real a tour video
has somebody leave fossils it it
phosphate in 2017 Frances president
Emmanuel macron came to power at the
head of a brand new party promising a
new and more representative kind of
politics but two years in an Emmanuel
macron critics say he's just another
fully paid-up member of france's
traditional political class it doesn't
help that he studied here at the college
that most symbolizes the aloofness of
france's political elite we are in the
old enna which is the national school
for administration it's the school
dedicated to the civil servants orally
Philip petty used to be a government
minister and also studied at an elite
college or Conde Col as they are known
Anna is the most elite of the Condor
Coll where France's leading civil
servants come to learn their trade many
later become politicians four of the
last eight presidents of France studied
here
[Music]
anna has become a symbol of inequality
in the ni you have only a few persons of
the students will come from
working-class that's why the people in
France have developed a hate regarding
enough because in fact they feel as if
it was something unaccessible for them
or for their children in April 2009 teen
president macron proposed shutting down
Anna but Miss Philippa T believes this
will only paper over the cracks of a
deeper problem she says there is a
perception that politicians become
sucked into a remote metropolitan elite
that puts the interests of the capital
above the rest of the country the
closing of Anna will not be enough to
solve the problem the way politicians
live when they are in Paris is very
different that the way they live when
they are in their constituency sometimes
it's a kind of schizophrenia and because
our country is very centralized too much
centralization is killing France Mike
home when you write yeah it tried in
fact to say that he wanted to get people
from everywhere and to change that but
the people who choose in fact they all
come from the same social classes
but the disillusionment of French voters
is not about to lead to the death of
French democracy
83% still believe it is the best form of
government in France and in the Western
countries are really attached to
democracy they think it's the best
system we have made some studies about
the trust in democracy and in every
study you find that people think it is
the best system they don't want a
dictator and that's very important
however the growing disconnect between
people and elected politicians in France
is part of a wider trend in the West
since the failed wars in Iraq and
Afghanistan
politicians have increasingly been
viewed as incompetent after the global
financial crisis bankers in the City of
London and Wall Street had to be bailed
out ordinary people on the other hand
were expected to pay for it
by enduring austerity the problem in
countries in the West is that the
quality of democracy is in decline
you see people less satisfied that the
democracies they live in are producing
the goods you see people more cynical
about their politicians less ready to
believe that politicians are working on
their behalf in the world's most
powerful democracy that sense of
cynicism towards elected representatives
is growing today only 17% of Americans
say they can trust the government to do
what is right compared with 40% in 2000
[Music]
in a representative democracy the
electorate mostly only get a say at the
ballot box that means the system relies
on voters interests being effectively
protected by those they elect in
American politics lobbying plays a
central role in helping politicians make
informed choices lobbying in itself you
know it is part of the American Way and
generally speaking it works okay it's
hard to explain that it sounds pretty
seedy and bad but you can't pick and
choose who should lobbying what's good
and what's bad that's up to the
politician to figure out the idea is
that the senator or congressman takes an
enlightened and broad view of his or her
constituents interests it is important
that they hear from business and they
hear from you know nonprofits a lot of
interest groups who have their own
perspective the problem in American
democracy today is that the interests of
business often drown out those of
citizens in 2018 3.5 billion dollars was
spent on lobbying in Washington up from
1.6 billion in 2000 and of the 100
organizations that spent the most on
lobbying 95 represent business that can
have a real impact on ordinary people
the nation is in the midst of an
unprecedented opioid epidemic America's
opioid crisis is rampant with an average
of 115 opioid deaths each day drug
overdoses are now the leading cause of
accidental death in our country and this
is a total epidemic the opioid crisis is
one example of how lobbying by wealthy
companies has clashed with the interests
of the electorate while some
pharmaceutical companies sought to push
opioids as a miracle cure for pain
millions of Americans became addicted
[Music]
my dream was to join an Olympic team
husam gay so I went to gymnastics
practice for four and a half hours every
day of the week and I never thought in a
million years that this is where my life
would be Elena is one of the victims of
the opioid crisis she now does outreach
work helping other drug addicts on the
streets of San Francisco in 2010 age 16
she was injured in a car crash and
prescribed opioids to relieve the pain
I started out instead you know and um I
woke up some days later in the hospital
I was on a trip and I remember singing
to myself you know I really like the way
this feels
[Music]
alena soon became addicted to the pills
she was given and found doctors were
only too happy to keep on prescribing
they were writing scripts for an opioid
painkillers like that can do addiction
it was like being in jail you can't just
like open the door and walk out of it
you can't you're here in DES and it
holds you there at the time this was a
pattern sweeping across America in
Washington most politicians were slow to
tackle this growing opioid crisis when I
was in Congress I became acutely aware
of the opioid epidemic as it hit my
family and my son became addicted to
pills in high school he thought that
they were the safer a drug to party with
and he he became addicted mary bono was
a Republican member of Congress between
1998 and 2013 during the height of the
opioid epidemic she co-founded the
Congressional group on prescription drug
abuse in 2010 and quickly discovered
that pharma companies were keen to play
down the crisis we had some industrial
opposition every step of the way we had
a lot of you know pharmaceutical
manufacturers and distributors and folks
saying that we were wrong and that were
making this up and that we were
overstating the problems miss bono
believes that politicians failed their
constituents by falling prey to the
influence of pharmaceutical companies
she says she experienced the unhealthy
influence of the farmer Lobby firsthand
by the time this hearing is over ten
Americans will have tragically and I
believe needlessly died from
prescription drug overdoses Purdue
Pharma had sent in a lobbyist and a
former member of Congress with the
explicit reason to politically threaten
me that if I continued my work on the
opioid epidemic that they would defund a
prescription drug monitoring database in
the state of Florida it actually sort of
became a little legend on the hill about
being threatened like this by if I'm a
member of Congress now if you go back
and they've been interviewed about this
and they deny it but it happened we have
a solemn obligation to tackle this
growing epidemic head-on and I'm going
to keep beating the drums until Congress
the FDA and the DEA come up with a
comprehensive plan for action
since 2000 pharmaceutical companies have
spent over four billion dollars lobbying
and funding election campaigns in
Washington although not all of this
relates to opioids it compares with just
four million dollars spent by groups
lobbying to limit opioid use this huge
disparity meant the pharmaceutical
companies were able to limit attempts to
change opioid prescribing patterns for
years it was very frustrating all along
because people were dying there's no
question that the lobbying efforts by
pharmaceutical manufacturers and
distributors stalled the response
[Music]
[Applause]
so like this is the part where the
prisons will be like [ __ ] like I for
by
[Music]
when legislation was passed in 2016
hundreds of thousands of addicts like
Helena turned to alternatives on the
black market such as heroin and fentanyl
I've been using heroin for close to
eight years now it's maintenance now I
don't get it I don't get high anymore
drugs now kill about seventy thousand
Americans every year more than car
crashes or guns a complex web of factors
underlies this but the crisis has
highlighted how far the powers of
corporations have risen relative to
elected politicians since the early
2000s the gap has widened between
spending on corporate lobbying and the
overall funding of the United States
Congress the attitude of corporations
towards government has gone from seeing
government as a threat to seeing
government as a potential opportunity
Lee Trotman is a political scientist and
a leading expert on political lobbying
in America what we've done is we've
really hollowed out Congress Congress
has D invested in its own knowledge and
capacity for four decades and it's
Dumber as an institution now and
corporate lobbyists are much more
powerful as a result one of the things
you can ask yourself is why do
businesses spend what they do the
extraordinary large sums that are being
spent is an indication of just what they
expects the political system to give
them in return
if constituents feel that their voice is
completely drowned out and at Washington
is producing bad policies because in
effect it's being bought then that is a
failure of democracy
we are going to Washington DC and we are
going to drain the swamp
spending on lobbying has increased by
nine percent since Donald Trump moved
into the White House despite him running
on the promise of cleaning up Washington
you know that phrase started about a
week ago and I thought it was terrible I
didn't like it at all I said I don't
know I just don't like it the people
like it that's much more important
president Trump won the election by
playing on the sense of dissatisfaction
with the political status quo we must
protect our borders from the ravages of
other countries making our products
stealing our companies and destroying
our jobs playing on grievance is a more
sure way to power and that is otherwise
known as populism president Trump is
part of a wider trend since the 1990s 46
populist leaders or parties have been in
power in 33 democratic countries the
worry about populism is that playing on
people's grievances and exaggerating
their differences tends to make the
political system less healthy and that
of course is bad for democracy
[Music]
democracies are historically thought to
die by the barrel of a gun but today
they are just as at risk of being
strangled slowly by populist leaders
claiming to act in the name of the
people
[Music]
when reach f-type uh dawuan became prime
minister of Turkey in 2003 he was a
force for democracy standing up to the
army which had launched one coup after
another
[Music]
over the years he has consistently been
elected but power has corrupted the
president and the country has slipped
into autocracy
[Applause]
in 2016 a faction of the military
attempted a coup but it failed and
president Erdogan ramped up his
consolidation of power
[Music]
[Applause]
today marks three years since the failed
coup attempt and president erdogan
supporters are celebrating the
anniversary Janet I bailed on you still
believe their business on my guitar are
consummate Turkey is now one of the
least democratic countries in Europe but
the president still retains the support
of around half the population never
mangu should be leader yes sir I'm
impatient then surely it dollar will do
mr. moochick atom boo dictator boo mr.
Wilke tech machine I own it here the
president has claimed to be defending
democracy while actually eroding it
since the coup attempt he has purged the
state bureaucracy and civil society
arresting around 80,000 people and
censoring the media
[Music]
we are in a car repair district of
istanbul and this is what the free media
looks like in turkey Katri girsl is a
Turkish journalist
he's just been released from prison
after criticizing the government
the regime took advantage of the
circumstance to muzzle the press I was
accused for deliberately and
intentionally helping terrorist
organization hundreds of opponents of
the president have been tortured in
prison while mr. girsl escaped this
brutality he spent 11 months behind bars
it was a gross injustice the best way to
keep the integrity in prison is not
thinking about the other words my
formula is simple you don't think about
about things that you love but there is
a glimmer of light for democracy in
Turkey in March Akram
Imam or glue an opposition candidate won
the Istanbul mayoral election by a slim
margin edwin has taken a grip through
the ballot box it means he could still
be challenged in the doubt ballot box
now it's not a fair contest but as long
as there are votes there are always
opportunities to have upsets and this is
just a sign that err doin who had
everything going his way actually was
vulnerable
an angry president herda one insisted
that the election be rerun Istanbul
beauty ability of astronomers sitting
there in their organ is a video source
of their Tom currency the gamble didn't
pay off the rerun was lost by huge
majority
[Music]
this was really embarrassing and it
shows that Turkish people is a strong
dedication to say God the last
democratic resort which is the ballot
box and they like it and they won't let
it be hijacked
[Applause]
[Music]
democracy's across the world are
suffering from a crisis of confidence
but they can renew themselves democracy
is not an all-or-nothing entity people
are feeling their democracies are not as
healthy as they were they're less
satisfied with them does that mean
they're no longer democracies of course
it doesn't that's ridiculous but it does
mean that the quality of their
democracies decreased
today around 10% less of the world's
population live in a full democracy
compared with a decade ago
[Music]
inspiration may come from unlikely
places countries where democracy does
not exist on the streets of Moscow and
Hong Kong young people who never lived
in a democracy realize there's something
dignified about without democracy and
it's something we need to remember as if
we're lucky enough to have been born in
democracy it's worth striving